hi there today we're looking at chip
placement with deep reinforcement
learning by azalea me Rossini on a
Goldie and a long list of authors that I
have no stamina to read down I'm sorry
so this work is a cool application of
reinforcement learning to the real world
and we're gonna go through it and the
cool thing about it is it pulls together
parts from so many different areas of
machine learning and also here chip
engineering so what's the fundamental
problem the fundamental problem of chip
design is is this you have a canvas an
empty chip and you want to build a
computer chip now what you have given is
a so-called netlist so your netlist is
any parts that you want on the computer
chip and their shape or their size so
you can imagine this like a bit of a
Tetris game so here is this netlist
there's this part and then this part and
then there's maybe this part and also
this part many many parts now these as I
understand it can be thousands of parts
but you can sort of group them together
but still there are a lot of these parts
and the netlist also contains
information about how they're connected
so for each of these parts you would
have a list of which other ones of these
parts they must be connected to right so
maybe it says okay this part here needs
to be connected to those three parts and
for each of those you'd also have like a
list of how they must be connected you
can represent this as an adjacency
matrix right but ultimately this is a
graph of these nodes now your goal is to
place those things on this board so for
example we're going to place this right
here and we're in a place the second one
maybe here and the third one maybe here
so you can imagine if this is a CPU
maybe look I have no clue of chip design
but I imagine it like this this is your
a clock that you need on there this is
your NAND gates right NAND gates pretty
important for a CPU and this is your
floating-point unit also pretty
important and so on so need to place
these things and then you need to
connect them using these using wires now
wires are of course edged into the board
but you need to connect them according
to be maybe there is a component right
here according to the netlist right they
need to be connected like that maybe the
the algorithm that came up with the chip
told you they need to be connected like
this and if you lay them out like this
you can draw the wires so this is your
finished you you want to go from the
thing on the right to the thing on the
left and your goal here in order to get
the fastest possible computer chip is
three things first of all you want first
of all the density is important by
density it basically just means you
can't place stuff on top of other stuff
so you could not place a block right
here not possible because the clock is
already there right so that's first
thing you can't place stuff on top of
other stuff then the second thing is the
wires and specifically the length of the
wires so you see for example this thing
here is a pretty short wire that means
the signal travels fast this thing here
is a long wire so the signal travels
more slowly now the lower sorry the is
the faster you want your signal to go
that means you have to make your wires
as short as possible so you want to keep
the total amount of wire length as short
as possible and then third is what's
called congestion so congestion is when
for example okay I actually don't know
what it is but maybe it is when two
wires cross like some
here there might be congestion or maybe
some parts actually share their wires I
can imagine
sorry I want to draw this again I can
imagine maybe there's a part here that
wants to go up and then it maybe shares
sorry shares this part of the wire here
with the other one and so there's
congestion like it's roads or something
in in any case you can measure
congestion it's a bad thing and you want
to layout your components basically in
order to minimize congestion and also
minimize the length of the wires and not
have them on top of one another easy
enough right
it takes human experts and combined with
state-of-the-art algorithms multiple
weeks to design chips like this and
that's the fundamental problem and this
paper takes reinforcement learning in
order to solve this problem in a few
hours so how does it do this the
reinforcement learning is basically a
sequential measure method so you want to
do one action at a time so you start off
with what they call the chip canvas
which is just empty this is your state
and then the agent here it gets to
decide where to place the next thing now
how do you decide what the next thing is
and I believe they simply go by size so
they take the largest component first of
the netlist first and they just go down
the netlist like this so you tell the
agent hey agent I want you to place this
this thing here
I want you to place this next and the
agent will tell you I will place it
right here and then again you tell the
agent agent I have this this thing here
where do you want to place it along with
sorry along with all the connections
right along with everything that it
needs to be connected to and also the
entire list so the agent must also think
of what what is to come yet what it
hasn't placed yet
if everything goes into this decision
and it tells you okay I wanna place this
here and then at the end you end up with
this filled board now this isn't
actually the end after you have placed
all your things there is another method
coming in this is called this
force-directed method placing yet more
things so what you actually place with
this agent is only the things called
macros I have no idea what those are or
how these are different from these
standard cells but apparently you must
use a force directed method which you
can think of just just an algorithm you
run to place the standard cells and
these are these um these gray blobs here
and at the end of all of this you can
finally evaluate how good your design is
so at the end of all of this you get a
reward that is a mixture of wire length
and congestion now this is actually an
approximation to wire length and this is
an approximation to congestion that they
use because they need to evaluate it
quickly but in essentially it's highly
correlated with wire length and
congestion so then the negative of that
is going to be your reward so in terms
of a reinforcement learning problem this
is pretty nasty right because as you can
see here you get basically a reward of
zero for every step until the very end
you get your true reward and it is
actually worse than that because so from
here to here you your agent gets to
perform actions right this is action
time but usually when you have these
sparse reward tests you will get your
reward at the end of that action time
but not here at the end of the action
time there is a algorithm over which the
agent basically has no control that
comes in and does a bunch of things this
force-directed method and only then do
you get your reward right so the
agent must purposefully sort of leave
room here for what this algorithm is
going to do so it needs to learn that as
well this is a as far as reinforcement
learning goes this is a pretty good
reinforcement learning problem right so
now we have an environment which is the
canvas here and also this you can you
can consider this force directed method
to be part of the environment and of
course the reward Giver
and you have also the netlist as part of
the environment and you have the agent
that can do actions now we have to go
into how does the agent perform actions
on this so by the way may be a bit
confusing because it was a bit confusing
for me for a given reinforcement
learning problem we'll just start out by
saying that the netlist is always the
same right if you might be coming from a
deep learning framework where you're
used to many many different training
samples in this case basically the
netlist the goal is always the same
you can think of it like a reinforcement
learning agent for the game of chess
where it's always the same chess game
that you're trying to optimize this is
the difference - let's say supervised
learning if you have a label in
supervised learning if you know the
solution to a particular data point
you're happy right you that data point
is no longer interesting you want to
generalize here even though they
generalize later here you can give it a
single problem right and it will already
a solution to that problem will be
valuable because it can be a better
solution that humanity has come up with
until this point so always think that
we're now just working on one single
netlist one problem to optimally place
this netlist in an episode is simply to
place these things until here and then
you get a reward and then you go back to
the beginning and just do it all over
again but just try to do better and then
you go back to the beginning
and you do it all over again the same
problem right okay so how does this work
by the way that the paper has great
technical detail on chip engineering and
how the reward function exactly works
and so on I have not the expertise to go
into this with you beyond what I just
described all right so here is how the
model looks from a deep RL perspective
now there's two parts to this model you
can divide it about here so on the right
you would have what is your policy and
value networks and on the left the
feature embeddings so in reinforcement
learning and we won't go much into
reinforcement learning now but what you
need are basically a way to encode the
state this is the encoder so all the
information of the observation they
might be in different modalities and so
on you need to encode this into a in for
simplicity let's say a single vector
that's thing that this thing here this
is the state encoding and then you can
employ a policy and a value network in
order to do reinforcement learning
so the decide on the right this comes
from standard RL you have a policy
network and the value network and they
do I believe PPO with it this is a
standard reinforcement learning
architecture it's an actor critic
architecture so the value net is simply
telling you what's the value of the
states that you're in now even that you
have a state embedding it simply takes a
fully connected layer to transform this
into a single float that is the value
network the policy is a bit different
because usually in reinforcement
learning you just have a list of actions
right you just say I have these sixteen
buttons on my controller you compress
them here we if you are if you look at
this chip from above we have a question
where do you want to place the next
thing so in order
do that we take this embedding of the
state and they run it through a series
of D convolutions and the D convolutions
they have the ability to basically up
sample an image so you see here you
transform this vector into a 4 by 4 by
32 tensor and that gets D convolved into
more and more though less and less
channels but more and more height and
width images so it kind of from a vector
it produces an image right here you
might recognize this from a lot of
generator architectures for when you
make Gans for images have exactly this
deconvolution architecture so as I said
pretty cool it pulls in kind of
architectures and methods from different
fields we already have reinforcement
learning and now we have generators for
images now so you come up with an image
and basically this image if you can
imagine this from above is discretized
so you can place the thing you have to
place pretty much every single nanometer
but they discretize this into a grid and
for each point in the grid the network
outputs a number so the number may be 9
here 3 4 and so on 8 right here so for
each of these they it outputs a number
where it would or how much it would like
to place the next thing at this
particular location so this is a
distribution over locations so the first
thing you have to do is you have to mask
out where there are already things we
said the first condition is things
cannot be on top of other things so
maybe you already have placed something
here so you ignore those numbers and you
have already placed something here so
you ignore those numbers as well this is
this masking operation right here and
then you simply look at where is your
highest number and maybe there's maybe
there's an 11 down here somewhere say ah
this is my highest number okay cool and
you look at what you need to place maybe
the thing you need to place
looks like this and he say all right I
will place maybe the eleven marks the
top-left corner I will place it right
here okay and then you do the same thing
again for the next piece so the next
piece you would simply also mark this to
be blue so you can't place here you
evaluate your network again of course
you'll have a new shape something like
this and then you ask the network where
would you like to place this and you do
this step by step by step until the
entire netlist is empty so this is how
we do the reinforcement learning this is
how we decide on an action but how do we
actually put the state into this
encoding now this pulls in yet another
framework from another field of deep
learning namely graph convolutional
neural networks so since the netlist is
a graph right the netlist is again if
you have your Wow this is slow today if
you have your netlist right here with
the part right the shape or size
whatever and the list of things it needs
to be connected to then this forms
naturally a graph so you can transform
this into a graph with the things that
need to be connected connected by an
edge and they run a graph convolutional
network across that now in a graph
convolutional network you're trying to
take a graph like this and have
embeddings for the edges and the
vertices so ultimately you want what's
called a graph embedding in order to do
that you need to propagate information
along the graph usually as we said this
is done doctrine graph convolution if
you are in machine learning for a while
longer you might remember also things
like conditional random fields or
generally graphical methods that were
once popular and a kind of a precursor
to this so the way they do it is they do
it in an iterative fashion they have
multiple so they say this right here so
how do they embed a graph
they have nodes in the graph as we saw
before I want to draw this one again so
this is maybe VI VJ and VK now these
represent the pieces in the netlist that
you have to place so for each of those
it has a bunch of features right so the
features might be its size it's a leaf
they they have them somewhere here its
size may be how much power it uses and
also its x and y-coordinates if it is
already placed right so you start with a
vector like this and then you
iteratively do the following thing you
compute edge edge features by running
first these things so this is VI and VJ
for an for each edge you take its nodes
run them through this fully connected
layer so you embed the features of the
nodes you concatenate them and you run
it through another neural network layer
and that's how you get embeddings for
edges and then you update the embeddings
for the nodes again by taking the mean
embeddings of the edges so you do this
in an iterative fashion first you
compute the edges from the nodes and
then you compute the nodes from the
edges and so on right so this means that
information can now propagate through
the graph so information from this thing
propagates into this edge embedding and
then in the next step that will
propagate into this and then that can
propagate into this EJ
and this is the same as if you're used
to yeah something like a conditional
random fields over time if you have a
big graph like this the information from
any particular node will kind of
propagate out throughout the graph and
at some point you can sort of reach an
equilibrium where every one every one in
the graph knows about everyone else I
have not found how many times they do it
they simply say we repeatedly perform
the following updates
maybe that's somewhere and I just
haven't read it closely enough but also
I don't haven't seen whether or not they
then back propagate through this through
these multiple updates or whether they
just back drop through one of them not
entirely sure but ultimately they get
embeddings these edge embeddings out of
this graph and they simply take the mean
to get the graph embeddings and that
goes into their state embeddings right
along with that they also have the macro
embeddings which are the nodes here the
things to be placed along with the
current McCrady this is which one do you
need to place right now so this comes
out of these are the two things out of
graphs vertices and edges and then which
one you need to place right now it's
pretty important right so you take the
ones the one that you read need to place
this also goes into your embedding and
then you have some metadata about the
netlist like how many things there are
and so on and this is also embedded
using a fully connected layer all of
that goes into your embedding all right
so your embedding will contain all of
this information if you've done a good
job and if you trained it correctly so
this is the model now they do pre train
this encoder part right here
the encoder part it's it's also kind of
circular first of all they just generate
a giant list so they take this chip here
and they just run a policy network that
is maybe not super optimal but they just
run it a bunch of times in intermediate
States and they pre train the encoder to
predict the final reward for each of
these placements or sorry the the the
wire length and congestion and so on and
that pre trains the encoder but
ultimately you can train this with
reinforcement learning you can out let
it try to solve this board over and over
and over and over and it will get better
over time all right the last thing they
do is they do transfer learning now
finding a better architecture for a
single board is already better and
faster than the humans but what is cool
is that if you have now trained on this
one particular board with one particular
netlist where was it right we've we've
now trained on this particular netlist
this was this was our problem and we've
solved that we have a great solution can
we now when we get an atlas another
netlist so here is netlist - right it's
maybe a bit different so this one is
more longer and this one is here and so
on what if so we would have to start
again from scratch a train and
reinforcement learning agent on the
netlist - so maybe our ELL agent trained
on chess if we now want it to play go
you know we need to start over again but
they try to just transfer this to the
new one and astonishingly enough if you
train the same orell agent not only on
one netlist but on a set of netlist and
the biggest set they have is 20 so their
data set size is 20 and imagine how
small this is compared to supervised
learning but maybe think of this like
you train
20 Atari games and then it will play the
21st one much better than if you started
from scratch interestingly though even
zero shot embeddings tend to be pretty
good so they don't optimize for the new
thing at all and it's already better you
can see that here so if you train a
policy from scratch then you this here
then it takes a long time but if you
fine-tune a pre train policy it's much
shorter and interestingly enough at the
beginning it is already better than the
policy from scratch that means the
knowledge from one chip transfers over
to the other chip so the problems are
sufficiently close and that basically
means that if we now want to design a
new AI chip not only are we better
because of our L we're also faster
because we can transfer learn and they
show here that this effect basically
appears when you have a large enough
data set and again large here is just 20
blocks here you see one of these
placements on the left the zero shot
placement and on the right and
fine-tuned on that particular
architecture obviously me being an
expert in shape placement is it clearly
obvious that both are extremely good and
yes though actually more funny I find
this one where they compare human
experts to what their approaches and it
says the figures are intentionally
blurred as the designs right like why do
you put them like clearly I can't even
couldn't even judge if they're super
crisp I yeah alright I guess it's their
trade secret
so they compare this with the standard
algorithms for these things and not only
are they faster they are also better on
the metrics overall as I said I find
this to be a pretty cool work that pulls
in a lot of things from a lot of
different fields
at one point they say we propose a novel
graph convolutional architecture I'm not
sure that it is novel maybe it's novel
for this problem but I'm pretty sure
graph convolutional networks and things
like this have been around for a while
but again it pulls together things from
many different fields and applies them
very well
very well-engineered paper and a step
towards the singularity as now a I can
design AI accelerators how amazing yeah
humanity is doomed all right I invite
you to check out this paper if you're
still here please subscribe leave a like
and a comment and I'll see you next time
bye bye